I feel that be able officially fire your
wife we've been calling each other not
since we met I swear to God but now it's
just real not so fast
Tana mojo and Jake Paul had a wedding
but are they actually married like
legally paddleball that's me
we looked into it and there is not a
marriage license or certificate listed
under either of their names you may kiss
the bride even more their officiant is
not registered with Clark County which
he would have to be in order to
illegally marry the couple
[Applause]
Jake proposed to Tana in Vegas during
tannaz 21st birthday celebration on June
24
he really does spoil me and it's crazy
because it's like I really would love
you without all I mean that I feel like
I just have to say that every eight
seconds loving and there's all this
material I don't know whatever I'll shut
up thanks for the ring
thanks for daddy's rich and the ceremony
took place less than a month later in
Sin City on July 28th like everything
was unconventional you know you're not
supposed to see the bride before the
problem everything was unconventional
but we're so in dimensional but it was
almost like imagine if we had a normal
wedding is fun it wouldn't be it was it
was so much fun and now we're trying to
maintain that energy for all this
craziness but like it's all love we're
so dead the validity of their quickie
wedding has been under scrutiny by many
especially after Tana said this on her
reality show at Tana turns 21 don't get
me wrong I think a wedding is a very
serious thing but at the same time I
think Jake and I don't take things very
seriously I have a lot of love for him
but it's still something fun and
light-hearted that we're obviously doing
for fun and for content she later
responded with a lengthy Twitter thread
saying she understands people's
frustrations with this clip well the for
fun and content soundbite was from a
very long sentence lmao and was a little
salty to see it pulled out of context I
know that things have moved so fast or
unconventional and confusing but I love
Jake et has reached out to their reps
for comment